Tsutomu Yamaguchi died from stomach cancer.
The cancer part perhaps isn’t surprising
given that Yamaguchi is currently the only
person officially recognized by the Japanese
government as having lived through the atomic
bombings of both Hiroshima and Nagasaki.
(Note: There were actually well over a 100
or so others as well, perhaps as many as 165;
they just have never been officially recognized
by the Japanese government to date.)
What is surprising, given that history, is
that Yamaguchi avoided the disease for so
long, not dying until January 4, 2010, at
the age of 93.
At the age of 29, Yamaguchi was on his way
back home from a three month long business
trip to Hiroshima on August 6, 1945.
At the time, he was an engineer for Mitsubishi
Heavy Industries- specifically, working as
an oil tanker designer.
On his way to the train station to head back
to his home in Nagasaki, he noticed he’d
forgotten his travel permit and went back
to get it while his colleagues, Akira Iwanaga
and Kuniyoshi Sato, went on.
He picked up his pass and was on his way back
to the station when, at 8:15 a.m., he saw
a bomber flying over the city and “two small
parachutes”, then a rush of blinding light,
sound, wind, and heat knocked him to the ground.
Mr. Yamaguchi had the misfortune of being
approximately 3 km from a nuclear blast.
The immediate effects of this were his ear
drums rupturing, temporarily blindness, and
burns over much of his upper body.
After his initial disorientation, and in spite
of his injuries, Tsutomu managed to make his
way to an air-raid shelter where he met up
with his two colleagues who had also survived
the blast.
He spent the night in the shelter and in the
morning he and his co-workers headed back
to Nagasaki via train as originally planned.
When he arrived, he received bandage treatments
from a local hospital, and even felt well
enough to report for work on August the 9th,
just 3 days later…
(Now I feel like a bit of a pansy about taking
a full week off while I had the flu.)
Of course, Yamaguchi had to explain his burns
to his coworkers.
His boss was in disbelief over his claim that
it was a single explosion that destroyed much
of Hiroshima.
“You’re an engineer,” he said to Tsutomu,
“calculate it…how could one bomb destroy
an entire city?”
The boss spoke too soon.
According to Yamaguchi, during this conversation
the air-raid sirens went off and then, once
again, he saw a blinding white light.
He dropped to the floor immediately; he was
familiar with the drill.
Yamaguchi stated, “I thought the mushroom
cloud had followed me from Hiroshima.”
Both bombs exploded near the city centers
and both, interestingly enough, were just
about 3 kilometers away from Tsutomu’s position
at the time.
Despite this explosion being slightly more
powerful than the one at Hiroshima (21 kilotons
vs. 16 kilotons at Hiroshima), thanks to the
city’s uneven terrain and the fact that
many parts of the city were divided by water,
which prevented the extensive fire damage
that happened in Hiroshima, there wasn’t
nearly the amount of overall infrastructure
damage.
Yamaguchi himself experienced no immediate
injury from this second explosion, though
of course was exposed to another high dose
of ionizing radiation and medical supplies
to treat his existing burns were now in short
supply.
Interestingly, Yamaguchi almost didn’t have
to go through this ordeal twice.
Nagasaki was not the original target for the
second nuke- that was the city of Kokura.
However, thanks to a cloud covering Kokura
when the bomber arrived, they had to divert
to a secondary target, Nagasaki, as the mission
stipulated that they were not to drop the
bomb unless they had a visual of the target.
When the bomber arrived at Nagasaki, they
also found significant cloud cover, but because
they were low on fuel, it was not possible
to divert to another target, so they made
their run anyways, despite their orders.
When they got close, just before releasing,
they did have a brief visual to confirm their
location before dropping the bomb.
Had they had more fuel or there not been a
cloud cover over Kokura, Yamaguchi and a not
insignificant portion of the Japanese population
would have had their lives drastically changed,
some for the good and some for the bad.
Surprisingly, unlike so many others who experienced
even just one of the blasts, Yamaguchi went
on to live a long and productive life with
the only major permanent physical health problem
as the result of the bombings being the loss
of hearing in his left ear, though the burns
took some time to heal; he temporarily lost
all his hair; and he experienced a great deal
of psychological trauma, as one might expect.
He and his wife, Hisako, even went on to have
children, who all turned out perfectly healthy,
which at least at the time, not so much today,
was thought to be something of a miracle considering
both parents had been exposed to such high
levels of ionizing radiation.
Yamaguchi’s wife lived to 88, dying of kidney
and liver cancer.
Yamaguchi himself lived to the ripe old age
of 93 years old and for most of his life made
little mention of the fact that he’d been
present at both bombings.
He initially just registered as a survivor
of Nagasaki.
According to one of his daughters, his reasoning
for downplaying this, and not registering
as a survivor of Hiroshima as well, was his
robust health through most of his life.
He felt it would be disrespectful to the many
thousands who were not so lucky, health-wise.
Once in his 80’s, he changed his stance,
breaking his silence on the matter and officially
applying for recognition as a survivor of
both blasts, which was granted by the Japanese
government in 2009, shortly before his death.
He then dedicated the rest of his life to
campaigning for the disarmament of nuclear
weapons from all nations.
He even wrote a book outlining his experience,
which included many poems he wrote about the
event (Raft of Corpses).
Despite it all, Yamaguchi considered himself
lucky.
As he said shortly before his death, “I
could have died on either of those days.
Everything
that follows is a bonus.”